العديد من المشاهير اختاروا الزواج بنساء
اكبر سنا منهم دعونا نستعرض بعضهم النجمه
العالميه جنيفر لوبيز تكبر زوجها الحالي
الممثل الامريكي بن افليك بنحو ثلاث سنوات
هي قصه حب نشطه مجددا بعد 19 عاما من
انفصالهما عام 2004 المطربه العالميه
الشاكيرا تكبر طريقها بكيبي عشر سنوات هي
قصه حب امتدت لاحد عشر عاما واثمرت عن
طفلين قبل انتهائها رسميا في يونيو من
العام الماضي بريانكا شوبرا نجمه بوليود
تكبر زوجها الموسيقي الامريكي
باكثر من عشره اعوام جذب اهتمام العالم
بزفافهما الاسطوري في 2018 عاما الذي
استمر لاربعه ايام
نجمه البوب الامريكيه تزوجت من عارض
الازياء الايراني سام اصغر وا صغر يصغرها
ب 12 عاما الممثل الاسترالي هيو جاك من
يصغر زوجته الممثله ديبورا ليفرس بنحو 13
عاما وتمتد علاقتهما منذ 27 عاما